alright and with that we have a guy who
is in coaching nirvana an NFL head coach
only thirty two of these jobs and he's
got one of them he's Brian Flores the
new head coach of the Miami Dolphins
good morning coach how are ya how are
you I was doing great now coach how do
you get a head coaching job in the NFL
when you're not an offensive coach I
thought they only hired offensive
coaches nowadays well you know there's a
lot of great offensive coaches in this
league I think the guys were higher this
year each one of them you know I've had
you know how great years and had great
careers and they're worthy and deserving
again like you said there's only 32 of
these so it's an honor it's a privilege
it's a humbling opportunity and I'm just
I feel fortunate to have one of them hey
Brian this is Peter King I wonder now
you stayed in the division which always
has to be a difficult choice to want a
coach in the same division as Bill
Belichick what do you think this does
with your relationship with your mentor
going forward well the first thing I'm
saying
you know you guys mentioned it there's
only 32 of these jobs and you know for
me personally I wasn't chasing in a head
coaching job it's it's something that uh
you know I felt like it had to be the
right fit and not edition like Miami was
the right fit for me um my relationship
was Bill you know it'll be a little bit
different but and that will be competing
against each other but and I'll always
have a great respect for him and I think
I'm gonna be the same on his part I
really do he's been a mentor to me he's
been great to me for 15 years he's been
a you know a sounding board for me and I
don't I don't see that changing you know
the only thing will change when we play
each other for those 3-4 hours we won't
like each other and that that's okay
that's part of uh you know being
competitors and you know we're both
we're both you know going out to win
every
and we he knows that you taught me that
so I don't think it would be much of a
big problem hey Brian you mentioned
yesterday when you were introduced as
the coach of the Dolphins that there was
something during the interview process
that that spoke to you that clicked that
made it clear to you that was where you
needed to be can you give us something
tangible some example something that
allowed you to realize this is the place
where you need to start your career as a
head coach when I talked about this
yesterday there was some you know four
principles core values core beliefs they
were just they were aligned as far as
you know the things that you know I felt
we needed to build a team and to create
a culture of winning honestly I
interviewed as much of a degree that's
kind of the process you know I took
there and I asked a lot of questions and
a lot of those questions were answered
in a way that made me feel comfortable
I'm not going to get into the details of
that that that's it that the interview
I'm gonna keep that private it wasn't we
know obviously uh myself Chris these and
the leadership team here but uh I would
just say it was a it was a I walked out
of there feeling really good about on
the situation here and it's something
I'm excited about Brian I got to ask you
one question about very recent history
in the in the game on Sunday night in
the third quarter
Jason McCord II made a play that might
have saved the Super Bowl for you what
exactly was that play who should have
had Brandon cooks and how do you now
when you look at that play figure that
Jason McCord II was able to make the
play well the play we saw earlier in the
game and we talked about the play you
actually had to come a little bit better
earlier in the game and now you know
they went back to what we knew that
we're going to go back to it we had a
miscommunication Jason he made the play
of the game and it was an incredible
effort
is really what it was and that's
something we talk about on a day to day
basis you know here's a guy bright um
that we had a guy make a mistake
we gotta gotta cover for him and there
being the other play of the game I was
so happy for Jensen because you know
he's he's had you know it was always two
Campina year ago and um you know he came
here and he worked and this is with an
up and down season
and I'm so happy for him to a lot of win
it so Brian on that particular play is
it the responsibility of everybody in
your secondary when they see the ball in
the air if somebody sees that they just
have to go that it's a fire drill at
that point I mean yes you see if you see
the ball in here you go
you know thankfully Jason saw the ball
and you just felt the quarterback fill
it and you know play the game Brian
you're coming from one of the great
organizations that any sporting league
has ever seen and you're going to a team
that has struggled for years hasn't been
to the Super Bowl in more than four
decades changing culture can be
difficult you can meet resistance how
closely did you pay attention to what
Matt Patricia experienced in Detroit
this past year and what if anything have
you learned from that that may make it
easier for you in Miami
[Music]
I was pretty focused on what was going
on and that's going to be the case here
I think you know what change comes you
know there'll be some bumps in the world
would change I think changing the
culture like you said there's there's
you know there could be some resistance
but we'll work through that we'll do the
things that we think are necessary to
help this period
we'll do that on a day-to-day basis I
think you know Chris and I have talked
about this you know anything that helps
this team you know we're going to try to
do that and you know as consistent with
consistently as possible and not hurt
the team we're going to try to you know
do everything possible we can to turn
those negative and positive Brian how
much will you be involved with the
selection or of the next quarterback of
this team whether it be in the draft or
free agency or keeping Ryan Tannehill
what what is your role going to be with
you know basically the choosing of that
next quarterback the quarterback
position as part of that quarterback
hold on D line as well we're valuing
every every position so that will be a
collaborative effort prints myself the
coaches that the personnel staff again
we'll do what we think is best for the
Miami Dolphins and that again that would
be the BB collaborative we'll go through
the process of of evaluating this entire
team and you know we'll do we things
best at all positions hey Brian you seem
to be very committed to always being
yourself can you give us an idea and
Dolphins fans who may be listening to
this an idea of who Brian Flores will be
what kind of a style should they expect
in a head coach someone's gonna be
honest didn't try to tell the truth on a
day-to-day basis I'd like to get out of
fun of things and and and be transparent
but definitely demanding that for
someone who who you know was gonna try
to get the best out of you know everyone
you know I try to get the best out of
everyone I come across you know every
day I've just written on you know on my
wall here's
what can I do to help help you succeed
and that's kind of my my my goal here
was to help everyone in the building
succeed as players as coaches that's um
you know equipment that's that's media
public relations you know if I can I
will name back lodge that's why I got
into coaching and uh Brian that's what
you're gonna get no problem Brian one of
the things about being a head coach that
first time head coaches often say is
they didn't realize how much stuff other
than coaching is involved in the job and
particularly in New England you know you
guys are you know hidden in the leaf
pile basically you don't have to deal
with much at all with the media or
anything else other than just coaching
your guys so how different do you expect
that to be and what do you think about
all the other parts of your jobs that
are about that you're about to take on
head-on well thankfully I've had some
friends become head coaches and I've
been able to you know have a few
conversations about you know all those
other you know it's called sub programs
you know divisions of the program with
the organization that you know you have
to partake in and thankfully I've been a
part of I've worked in multiple was also
defense special teams personnel had a
hand in a few different programs so I
understand that this is a very different
role and you know and we put together
staff you know and we have some best
targeted I think it's important to bring
good people in and let them do their job
I think that's that's a big part of
leadership and I plan to do that
hey coach one more for you before we let
you run 15 years in New England Bill
Belichick clearly the dominant influence
there give me the next person who else
influenced you
other than Belichick the most during
your time in New England
there's there's a lot of guys I mean I
couldn't name one I could name four or
five year I started
dante's cornacchia these are all line
codes there and I actually tried to
powder my coaches fell out of his he's
been a great great offensive line coach
there for a long time he's an even
better human being so I start there I
mean I could go I could go for a little
while on this one it's got a Brian well
here's a coach the my radio people are
telling me we got to take a break so
what we'll do hopefully we can sit down
with you the Scouting Combine at the
league meetings and we can rattle off
all the other ones and any other
influences you've had because I think
it's a great story that you've put
together and we look forward to seeing
what you do in your time as head coach
of the Dolphins congratulations and all
the best and we look forward to talking
to you again soon
thank you all right all right there he
is Brian Flores new head coach of the
dolphin
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports